- [Narrator] A small city has become one
of the biggest battles in
Russia's war in Ukraine.
Moscow has sent tens
of thousands of troops
to Avdiivka in the Eastern Donetsk region.
But Ukraine says, many of
those men have been killed
on the battlefield, in
what's looking like a repeat
of the deadly fight for
Bakhmut earlier this year.
(tank fires)
- There's not really
anything left about Avdiivka
and that's the same as Bakhmut was.
- [Narrator] Here's why
Russia is determined
to take Avdiivka, no matter the cost.
Capturing Avdiivka would allow Russia
to tighten its grip on the Donetsk region.
(bomb explodes)
The city is located just over
30 miles south of Bakhmut,
but Avdiivka is more significant to Moscow
because it is close to Donetsk city,
which has been held by Russia since 2014.
As with Bakhmut, controlling Avdiivka
won't give Russia any
significant military gains,
but it would be a
propaganda win for Moscow,
something Ukrainian President
Volodymyr Zelensky says,
his Russian counterpart,
Vladimir Putin needs,
heading into winter.
- (Volodymyr speaks foreign language)
- [Narrator] Seizing
Avdiivka would allow Putin
to claim that the momentum in
the war is back with Moscow.
- Putin, after the initial
failure to take Kyiv,
announced that taking the
Donetsk and Luhansk regions
was the priorities and symbolically,
it would show that they're
still moving forward.
- [Narrator] Russia is pouring
large numbers of troops
into its assault and Avdiivka,
just like in Bakhmut earlier this year.
And also as in Bakhmut, Ukraine says,
this has cost Moscow thousands of men
and dozens of armored vehicles,
yet they've hardly advanced.
- For the Russians, a war of attrition
favors them a high casualty war.
Attrition favors that,
and they've been more
willing to just throw bodies
at an area to try to
take it than Ukraine has.
- The Russian Ministry
of Defense didn't respond
to a request for comment
about its assault on Avdiivka.
But Russian President
Vladimir Putin has said,
his forces were conducting active defense
along the whole frontline.
For Ukraine, as with Bakhmut,
Avdiivka is a symbol of resistance.
- (Maksim speaks foreign language)
(gun shots)
- [Narrator] The city has been
a Russian target since 2014
where Moscow first
launched a covert invasion
of Ukraine's Donetsk and Luhansk regions.
(gun shots)
While Russian forces are largely
in control of the Donetsk region,
Avdiivka remains a Ukrainian stronghold,
but Kyiv has not placed as
much rhetorical importance
on the city as it did with Bakhmut.
- You had Zelensky in
his nightly addresses
talking about Bakhmut,
basically every night
for months and months and
months, and he's not doing that
with Avdiivka in the same way.
He has not made it a
symbolic political point
to hold onto it.
(bomb explodes)
- [Narrator] Kyiv was
criticized for its decision
to defend Bakhmut, rather than retreat,
with critics saying Ukraine
had taken too many casualties.
(gunshots)
- I wouldn't be surprised if Ukrainians
are more willing to give up Avdiivka,
and I don't know that
they're gonna be so willing
to throw so many men at it
as they were with Bakhmut.
(gunshots)
- [Narrator] Analysts
say Russia's heavy losses
may undermine Moscow's long-term
offensive capabilities.
As winter approaches, season
control of new territory,
no matter how small, would be seen
as a win in Moscow's eyes.
(gunshots)
That says both sides have struggled
to seize any new territory this year
after troops spent months building up
defensive lines last winter.
- It's been very difficult
this year for either side
to significantly move the line,
and it looks like that trend
is continuing in Avdiivka,
and we'll see if that changes,
but it doesn't look like it so far.
(intense music)